[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 y hoy con un tema
más que interesante
la ciencia nos permite progresar como
sociedad nos permite entender el mundo y
nos permite entendernos a nosotros
mismos sin embargo está visto que muchas
veces las ciencias exactas no han
actuado como tal y han estado cargadas
de sesgos a lo largo de su historia
incluso llegando a ser
instrumentalizadas como herramientas de
discriminación en su libro La invención
de los sexos la doctora en estudios de
género y licenciada en biotecnología
lucichia expone un sesgo androcentrista
y machista que aún hoy Busca argumentos
en los laboratorios para mostrar a las
mujeres y a las comunidades diversas
como inferiores anómalas e incluso con
un destino natural Cómo Y por qué sucede
esto nos lo va a contar la autora a
continuación
realizó dos años de investigación en el
departamento de fisiología del sistema
nervioso de la Facultad de Medicina como
becaria en el conicet muchísima
información allí viendo incongruencias
en las metodologías Como por ejemplo que
los modelos utilizaban casi
exclusivamente sujetos masculinos para
los hallazgos pues ella decidió cambiar
el enfoque de su investigación y lo
movió hacia terrenos más feministas al
final determinó con una investigación
sobre el discurso neurocientífico acerca
de la diferencia sexual ahora es
investigadora en el centro de
investigaciones de estudio de género de
la Universidad Nacional Autónoma de
México y con ese prontuario tan grande
que además incluye premios una
bienvenida para usted Lu Gracias por
estar en ella soy Muchísimas gracias
Ángela vos por la lectura detallada y
por la invitación estar acá para mí está
buenísimo Bueno pues estoy tratando de
ser lo más cuidadosa que puedo para
tratar el tema con el con el respeto que
se merece luz porque yo se lo tengo que
decir muy Honestamente la inversión de
los sexos es una revisión histórica que
a mí me Voló la cabeza es un trabajo
excepcional Porque además de
reinterpretar las verdades que conocemos
de siempre lo hace con enfoque de género
y esto no pasa al menos no muy seguido
cuando uno está hablando de ciencias y
más de ciencias exactas usted comienza
con Aristóteles no hablando de esta
teoría de Aristóteles de los cuerpos
calientes y los cuerpos fríos Entonces
los cuerpos calientes masculinos más
fuertes los cuerpos fríos femeninos más
débiles incluso Aristóteles llega a
explicar que la definición del sexo de
una persona puede darse por la
temperatura en el momento de la relación
sexual y siendo justos porque lo dice su
prólogo en el libro esto es real para
algunos reptiles pero cuando uno habla
de seres humanos la cosa cambia y cambia
bastante es una complejidad distinta
cuando hablamos de personas Pero aún así
las ciencias exactas tienen sesgos Y
esto es es una conmoción en sí misma
usted habla de los dimorfismos empecemos
por ahí
bueno muchas cosas la primera que diría
es no hay ciencia que no sea sesgada si
entendemos el sesgo como una orientación
forzada a Qué quiere decir que no hay
ciencia sesgada que no existe la ciencia
neutral como tal porque no hay ciencia
que no esté permitida de intereses eso
no desvalida la producción de
conocimiento sino que nos hace situar
esa producción de conocimiento en
contextos históricos políticos
culturales específicos En ese sentido
cuando hablamos del cuerpo hablamos de
sesgos androcéntricos que quieren decir
orientados a respaldar los privilegios
del sujeto androcéntrico definimos este
sujeto androcéntrico como una
masculinidad hegemónica Si se quiere que
sería las seis masculinidad adulta
propietaria Blanca heterosexual
occidental por sí me refiero al prefijo
que se usa para describir a las personas
que se continúan identificando con el
género que les fue asignado al nacer
este sujeto androcéntrico es el que a
partir de la modernidad desarrolla y
articula la idea de dimorfismo sexual es
decir que existen dos formas biológicas
a partir de las posibilidades
reproductivas y esta idea estuvo
inextricablemente vinculada a el cerebro
de hombres y el cerebro de mujeres para
partir de esta justificación biológica
naturalizar lo que fue la polarización
de los roles sociales donde las mujeres
fue reducida al ámbito doméstico y el
espacio público pareció ser propiedad de
las Islas masculinidad blanca y usted
aquí nos está definiendo básicamente las
primeras olas del feminismo en una muy
pequeña introducción si se pone todo en
contexto no
mire este libro pone en cuestión un
binarismo que está socialmente aceptado
que es natural para al menos para
nosotros Porque existimos en un mundo en
el que debe ser natural que nos educó
para discriminar hombre mujer blanco
negro fuerte débil estas dicotomías Que
tanto se mencionan en el libro para
hablar de lo que somos y en este
supuesto orden existen unas anomalías y
unas minorías y esta se llaman
diversidad no la comunidad lgbtiq más
aquí le pregunto primero es real que la
comunidad lgbtiq más es una minoría y
segundo Es realmente
una comunidad anómala bueno los segundos
no como parte de la comunidad diría lo
que hay es una normativa es decir una
normativa que hace que a partir de una
genitalidad pensemos que está
determinada la identidad de género La
orientación sexual de una persona para
partir de esa normativa castigar como
marginalidad desde la idea de desvío y
patologización a que por uno más motivos
nos corremos de esa normativa es decir
personas que somos miembros de la
comunidad lgbt eso en primer punto y con
lo anterior que me que me preguntabas Yo
siempre digo que no hay una minoría en
términos de cantidad no sabemos Cuántas
personas hay primero Quienes se animan A
cuestionarse quiénes son segundo quienes
salen del clóset de una sociedad
transodiante lesbodiante etcétera Pero
al mismo tiempo da igual la cantidad
vamos a seguir siendo siempre minoría
porque somos minoría por la calidad de
lo que planteamos es decir de alguna
manera cuestionamos el orden físico y
simbólico de las normativas de género
diciendo una genitalidad no determina mi
ser y estar en el mundo una genitalidad
no da cuenta algo tan complejo como es
la expresión de género la identidad de
género y la sexualidad de una persona y
esto está perfectamente digamos
sustentado en el libro no no solamente
es algo que sale por inspiración sino
que está sustentado en la ciencia no la
biología hace su tarea nosotros en la
naturaleza y después la ciencia exacta
lo que ha hecho es reinterpretar eso
para traerlo a los cánones de lo que
está socialmente aceptado ahora la voy a
citar la categoría sexo nunca tuvo como
fin una descripción neutral de los
atributos biológicos vinculados como la
reproducción sino que su fundamento fue
la asociación con los roles sociales ese
fundamento luz usted lo decía al
principio muy rápidamente Además porque
es mucha información la que tenemos para
para recibir aquí en la genitalidad y en
el cerebro humano y menciona un
personaje francés Joseph gaale que
argumentó que las mujeres tenemos menor
capacidad porque nuestra frente nuestra
cabeza y por lo tanto tal vez nuestro
cerebro es más pequeño no y menos
elevada Entonces es nuestra inteligencia
que la de los varones y por eso estamos
hechas entre otras cosas para cuidar
niños para amar y para hacer las Dueñas
y señoras de la casa eso es ciencia o
estereotipo bueno Yo diría que
claramente son presupuestos
androcéntricos no Y esos presupuestos
Andro forman parte de lo que es la
ciencia el problema es pensar que la
ciencia es objetiva neutral y universal
es decir que los presupuestos que hay en
la ciencia tienen como es la ciencia Una
institución es parte de la sociedad
tienen Por supuesto premiadez sesgos que
implican estereotipos esos estereotipos
que llamamos de género que son ideales a
los que las personas nos ajustamos para
ser inteligibles pero de ninguna manera
son naturales Cuando vos me preguntabas
es una anomalía o no hablar de
diversidad sexogenérica y sexual tenemos
que pensar en realidad si es natural el
hecho de ser varón o mujer la anomalía
es pensar que eso es un hecho natural yo
siempre pongo en cuestión un experimento
mental Y es que nos imaginemos que
nacemos en una isla y que no conocemos a
nadie en nuestra especie y que de
repente nos vemos ahí nos miramos la
genitalidad y con ver la vulva yo voy a
decir mujer evidentemente Eso no
sucedería porque el ser mujer es un
hecho relacional porque no está
codificado en los genes ni inscrito en
los cerebros de nadie ser mujer tiene
que ver con una relación entonces socio
histórica política y cultural no esa
histórica y transcultural y el no
identificarme con ese género asignado al
nacer habla entonces de la misma forma
entender el ser y estar en el mundo no
natural sino relacional y a través de
mis trayectoria vital y mi experiencia
singular puedo cuestionarme mi
sexualidad mi identidad de género
expresión de género sin por eso será no
maldad sino que solamente estoy viviendo
y estando viva cuestiono aquello que me
dijeron que era un hecho natural sin que
nadie lo corrobore científicamente
porque esto es muy interesante A lo
largo del libro lo que muestro es que
esta historia acerca de dos cerebros hoy
no tiene validez científica no Y eso es
muy interesante y al mismo tiempo que
aunque la tuviera en los cerebros no voy
a encontrar Dónde está la identidad de
género de una persona porque eso implica
un verbo psicológico que es el deseo y
el deseo no puede reducirse a ningún
dato biológico Por más exhaustivo que
este sea mire esto es Demasiada
información yo definitivamente lo que
les tengo que pedir a las personas que
nos ven es que lean el libro porque
luego tiene una característica Y es que
lo cuenta todo con una particularidad
siendo tan ameno siendo tan tranquilo
traduciendo un lenguaje científico a un
lenguaje tan cotidiano y es importante
entender Como por ejemplo no por el
hecho de ser mujeres tenemos un destino
en términos de reproducción o en
términos de roles en la sociedad Y eso
ha quedado demostrado múltiples veces en
la historia como ya nos estamos quedando
sin tiempo y como es imposible resumir
su libro en una pequeña entrevista
quisiera ir finalizando con una
declaración muy potente que usted hace y
es lo que nos decía de La Isla nadie
nace trance nadie nace sí nadie nace
heterosexual usted Nos invita en la
conclusión de su libro hacer una lectura
que sea Revolucionaria de los cuerpos
donde empieza esa Revolución y también
con el sustento de la ciencia bueno es
buenísima tu pregunta la revolución
empieza en casa la revolución empieza en
ese ámbito que supuestamente está
despolitizado y en realidad es uno de
los más políticos es como entre nuestros
afectos nos leemos corporalmente si
estamos buscando la genitalidad de las
personas y de nosotros mismos para saber
quiénes somos Estamos reproduciéndose
sesgos androcéntricos que implican
subordinar ciertos cuerpos a costa del
privilegio de unos pocos entonces la
revolución empieza a cuestionándonos qué
pienso de mí que es natural
nos deja mucho para pensar luyo de
verdad le agradezco por poner en el
papel por haberse tomado el arduo
trabajo de hacer una revisión desde
galeno hasta la actualidad para ver cómo
la ciencia ha intentado dividirnos por
sexo o más bien por lo que es una
interpretación del sexo y como nosotros
estamos en la capacidad también desde la
ciencia para rebatir esos argumentos y
para vivir la vida que nosotros queremos
Muchas gracias muchas gracias a vos
Ángela por la invitación y a todos por
escuchar y a nuestros televidentes se
continúen en France 24 y nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas